[Music] It's a
new measure
Omata got the item he wanted
Yuuki Hirachi discovered function 3 It's a dried
product Ahsass Let's try it immediately Swan After this, use 3 types
Gomi  Mr. is used as a herbal medicine in medicinal dishes. If
possible, it's a bear meat hamburger that uses Nishikuma's fat and lean meat as a match.
Are you succeeding then
immediately
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
rar
Romiko has been treated as a herbal medicine with 5 tastes as its name suggests.It is said that
each taste brings benefits to different
organs.These 5 tastes and flavors are the clouds  The kimono c is packed in a well-balanced way, and the appearance is impressive and impressive.
Mr. Gomi uses it after being immersed in Japanese history.
You know the characteristics of Gomiko very well There's a guy who knows a lot about it before it's
air-fired.
Tomorrow's Gomija tea
is effective in improving nutritional strength and weakness.In the
first place, Gomi's tree is widely distributed in the Korean Peninsula of China, and even in Japan, Hokkaido and Honshu are resting.